[Music]
my home is it safe the hospital isn't
safe there way to the hospital visits a
dangerous and booming are everywhere I
can't find any place that I trust it
will be safe for me
we've just received a case resulted from
a last attack by the Israeli Air Force
he suffered from multiple a sharpen in
lower limb and a severe head trauma
he is semi conscious or unconscious most
of the cases where children and women
and elderly people
she's a camo mark Jeff Jeff
[Music]
we still expected to have more and more
injured people we still we still can
hear the you know that we can can be cut
[Music]
from time and yes still but there's a
you know a generator and the actual work
soon we hope
[Music]
it's unbelievable
we're not taking it just about one
Street or two or four five six it's a
whole area when it suddenly above the
heights of the people without veganizing
who's inside those houses and everything
actually bombed totally without telling
the people to go out of their houses
it's accepted to be a real massacre just
in those area Sharia we're about 100
more than 104 we're killed in the same
area if you just go a little bit further
that you with feeder is really army
until this moment I'm talking to you and
there is air strikes above me Hallett
cooked us any time they can bomb again
and again so this is for people who in
need I cannot have it but but look at it
like what Israel can do for this is it
is it a war machine is it a weapon is it
dangerous for Israel Society
since I was a kid I was really fond of
fashion design and I love to draw I love
to hold the pen and drove it's what I
used to do in my spare time maybe it
gives you a chance to stay away from
these stressful situations to draw
something far away from the death just
you see death everywhere all I do now is
just trying to show the world what's
going on in here through social media
because we can see that the mainstream
media these days are not showing the
truth they're actually twisting the
truth so the most important way to have
an open window to the world to show them
what's really going on and ground this
happens through social media like
Twitter Facebook and all these websites
I'm showing for my family and you know
at the the day light it is less
dangerous for us to come it'll go out
and they're shopping every day we say
yeah it's each other we are sick of this
situation we see the death we hear the
bombardment everywhere we can't live our
normal life what's happening here is a
fight and a struggling for a better life
we don't love this kind of situation
with that love this life right now we're
going to enter the most place you can
witness for humanitarian disasters and a
crisis this applies
unbalanced car winter forward children
who just came out from an ambulance and
I think that this is a big another
humanitarian crisis
I can witness this happen from the where
Israel or with Spanish young people and
certainly with no any excuses or reasons
Sydney an immoral to target children and
and and those of you I have another life
he comes back every time I'm kind of
traumatized when we ask him about how it
was he even sometimes stays silent and
sometimes he just say it was terrible
and just have enough with that it does
not really describe what he sees I guess
he comes back every time shock that he
does not want us to experience what he
experienced we are trying to keep our
emotions of aside trying to be
professionals at our words sometimes we
couldn't was a bombing on the lg Jaya
there was a lot of injured people a lot
of casualties out of marches I stand
there in the ER and I so there is no
place to place a foot and the one idea
that I was controlling me as is there
another day welcome well I see my family
again but after that I just realized
that I should control my feelings and my
emotions and to continue to give the
medical service for the injured people
and to give our best the situation that
affected me the most in this assault in
Gaza was the moment when I showed the
video the massacres happening in Syria
people thrown in the streets that
children women it was terrible so I was
chocked for a moment and I are just
stood there in front of my laptop and I
I couldn't tweet anything I couldn't
write anything I couldn't do anything
but just cry and then after I
well now you see what we live every day
and after a few moments I put myself
together and I posted the video and I
told the world that this is what's going
on in Gaza
I didn't see my daughter more than one
month so I am going to see my daughter
[Music]
see her Hey actually I only lived in la
Festa t so it's very far away from Gaza
it's about 45 minutes by the way in the
car because of the war actually and the
aggression I couldn't come to Gaza
because no one could go out for his home
that time and I used this ceasefire to
come to Gaza and to take to pick William
[Music]
I wish a good future for Maryam I want
her to be herself
I want Miriam to be as the future she
wants actually and this is it to be with
me always I don't want to lose her from
the Israeli army or bomb being
I don't know how would you describe
being a home every minute waiting for
the next bountiful on your house or to
kill someone of the people you love or
your family members is that living
that's not living we win the fight for
our life whatever that life as we can
well when I live in peace I want Miriam
to live in peace I want her to look
beside and around her I want her to see
everything is good not damaged
[Music]
you